[Musica]
cosa facciamo adesso no ma non lo so ma
mi ha fatto portare un cambio quindici
sotto par e si fa sotto per la cosa più
facile
dipendiamo non ci sono animali
pericolosi vero non so niente forse
hanno paura di voi maledizione
niente 3 quello se ci sono animali o
chiamate ammazzo non devo vedere insetti
fritto liberamente ma michael quei
gadget top cornelis funkart open
in che senso cosa devo fare per scavare
la mia tomba che non scavarmi la tomba
no dovete sottrarmi devo stendermi poter
negli ambienti sotterranei il dottore
questo cosa c'entra e con esperimenti in
crisi perché esserci un motivo se
rientriamo completamente libera perché
ma non c'è un motivo non è completamente
completa e uno schifo
dobbiamo seppellirti tutto compreso la
faccia che schifo
segue tempio no sono troppo poco a poco
con l'accetta
no non soffochi tranquillo io li faccio
come respiro che non ha pensato questo
ma dai dai temi seri dai questa roba
[Musica]
dottore oggi risolto per la festa dei
morti buon halloween a tutti e buon nei
giorni di esperimento dovessero finiti i
capelli benvenuti a capitolo 2 di
esterni nei topi fare vi dono tutti
storico capitolo 2 di esperimenti canili
dove è iniziato con nuove puntate in
concomitanza di festa dialogo in
pacchetto torre fan dei morti tra tori
avervi fatto studio per mostrare come
vedete siete soci tante cose nuove cose
che uscire da esperimenti che doveva
questa mattina ha scritto sul muro
perché non avere soldi per fogli non
avere budget oggi pare esperimento con
zucca cosa significa significa che totò
ne abbia limitato che zucche essere
problematiche a livello estetico perché
non avere capelli belli come quelli di
scienziati basement analogico pare fare
crescere i capelli a zucchero
[Musica]
doveva questo esperimento aver dovuto
fare operazioni chirurgiche ad aprire
zucca prima di tutto e inserire
all'interno di zucca e ciotola strana
primo ingrediente che inservienti potrà
essere sappia di canti quello caduto
reinserire sacrificato all'interno di
testa di su thor happines avere un
ottimo d'ore questa strategia può
inserire all'interno di giocare fino
quasi quasi a riempire non strofa però
abbastanza abbondanza di cazzo
una volta che sappia di gatta inserita
dove amalgamare con mano un po come
gatti fare quando grattare unghie una
volta in salita sabbia di gatto passare
al secondo ingrediente di esperimento
già abbonato essere questo zucchero
essere questo misurare con bilancia
uscita proprio non secolo scorso ma
l'altro ieri su amazon inserire qua
dentro
circa 50 grammi di miscela tra zucchero
e bicarbonato dove di zucchero mettere
il 40 grammi di bicarbonato mettere 10
inserire 40 grammi di zucchero non sul
tavolo ma su
bilanci per inserire 40 grammi di
zucchero all'interno di contenitori in
con territorio apposito perché poi
andare a miscelare con bicarbonato di
sorrisi aver sbagliato mia quindi fare
così come quando fare pasta dove ora far
vedere quanto esperimento essere
importante per vita di tutti
indispensabile fare crescere i capelli
zucca cambia sorti di pianeta tutorial
esso infarto e molto divertente
nell'esperimento ma dove ricodare voi
che voi non potere fare questa cosa che
poi non fa che questa volta capito dove
poterla fare qui quindi tutorial vento
tanto questa non essere a casa di pat
over se andare a poco chissenefrega
per fare questo esperimento necessità e
di zucca completamente il piano vuol
dire che deve essere dritta come
cervello di beta gli ambienti molto più
efficiente di quanto totò ne pensasse
adesso essere arrivato un momento molto
importante ovvero riempire di liquido
cosa tutta zucca liquido o va a servire
per fare reazioni di esperimento perché
liquido rosa servirà per dare corpo poi
non pare a casa tutte cose mi raccomando
aleggia dotare creare un ente con
miscela precedentemente creato enel
saggiatore dare finalmente
[Musica]
il dottore avere generato cosa che
sapete fare meglio nella sua vita corna
comunque sia questa zucca essere molto
molto molto prestante perché avrei fatto
questi spavento 80 si volti ad esito
torre spiegare come avvenire questa
magia di corna generatasi e non venire
da mogli e sky mentre il sito perché
mediante l'altro che ne sarei in
commissione avere sciolto zucchero ha
benedetto un posto bicarbonato che
liberare anidride carbonica queste corna
essere generate da miscuglio tra
zucchero essere sciolto e carbonio
generato da combustione di tutto
gonfiate danni dell'inter mondo dove
notato però che aveva funzionato solo
una parte di questo e corno essere
staccato quindi come giustamente dice
niente da area scotch e adesso dove
attaccare l'ultimo pezzo è rimanere
attaccato partito torre sapere
attaccarvi costi
[Musica]
la storia è finito per gli scali netto
di halloween sperare di vito vi sia
piaciuto è stato molto istruttivo è
stato molto necessitare di nuovo camicie
un sapiente procurare grazie totò è
molto contento angolari buone feste e
buon allerino dei codardi che stagione
gli esperimenti incredibile essere
ripartita quindi da oggi stabilimenti
molto molto molto migliori anche con
studi nuovo e sperone ricaribile essa ci
sono il sabato oggi e serve una puntata
speciale perché so che a lui ma non
tutti i sabati solo una volta ogni due
settimane anche voler dire che quando
esserci esperimento poi settimana dopo
non è socio esperimento però quella dopo
ancora esso accessori mente un
esperimento ogni due settimane di
esperimenti credibile uscire una volta
di due settimane di santo vederle
l'esperimento perché fare cose
incredibili quest'anno quindi ragazzi
sperare che non questo tavolo e sarà
intercambiabile se non dover pagare io
ci vediamo con il sì ma episodi
ferimento lasciare mi piace iscriversi
al canale speciale campanella paga tutte
cose noiose ma importanti per dottore e
noi ci crediamo ad un prossimo bivio
pulire tutto grazie
[Musica]